THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING WILL NOW
CAN BEAN UM WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
ONE BILL TODAY. SP 552 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. HE WILL BE HERE
MOMENTARILY. WE ARE PURSUANT TO
NEW SENATE PROCEDURES. ALL
TESTIMONY WILL BE LIVE IN
PERSON. UM SO LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SENATOR WIENER
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT SARTO.
YEAH. PRESENT BLAKE SPEAR.
CABALLERO CORTESI CAMARO PRESENT
ORTEZ E. JONES JONES PRESENT
PADILLA PRESENT. SKINNER AMBERG
AMBERG PRESENT, HOB HOB PRESENT.
OKAY, WE HAVE A QUORUM. UH
SENATOR NEWMAN. WELCOME. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MR CHAIR
MEMBERS. GOOD AFTERNOON. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT SP 552, WHICH PROVIDES
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO THE 2017
REVISION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SWIMMING POOL ACT, A MEASURE
WHICH I CARRIED AND WHICH WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY THEN GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN. BEFORE I BEGIN. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND HIS
STAFF ARE WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL AND COMMIT TO
INTRODUCING AMENDMENTS AT THE
NEXT OPPORTUNITY THAT ALLOWS FOR
MANUAL POOL COVERS. TO REMAIN ON
THE LIST OF ELIGIBLE POOL SAFETY
DEVICES FURTHER AFTER PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WITH BOTH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
OPPOSITION WHO I UNDERSTAND OR
NOT ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY, BUT
FOR WHOM WITH WHOM WE ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO COMMIT TO LOOKING INTO
THE OTHER POINTS RAISED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS. THESE
INCLUDE CONSIDERING THE ROLE OF
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION VERIFYING THAT THE
REFERENCE BUILDING STANDARDS AND
IDENTIFYING WAYS IN WHICH THE
STATE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
EFFICACY OF THESE ANTI DROWNING
SAFETY DEVICES. ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. DROWNING REMAINS ONE OF
THE LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN AGED 14 AND YOUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA, ESPECIALLY CHILDREN
WENT THROUGH FOUR WITH ROUGHLY
75% OF ALL FATAL CHILDHOOD
DROWNINGS OCCURRING AT HOME
SCHOOLS OR INSPIRES TELL BETTER
PREVENT SUCH TRAGEDIES THAT
CALIFORNIA SWIMMING POOL SAFETY
ACT OF 1996. REQUIRED
RESIDENTIAL POOLS TO BE
INSTALLED WITH AT LEAST ONE ANTI
DROWNING SAFETY DEVICE SUCH AS A
POOR FINCH, A POOL COVER OR A
BACKYARD DOOR. EXIT ALARM SP 442
OF 2017 EXPANDED AND ENHANCED
THOSE PROTECTIONS BY INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF REQUIRED SAFETY
FEATURES FROM 1 TO 2, AS WELL AS
REQUIRING HOME INSPECTORS TO
DOCUMENT FOR NEW HOMEBUYERS,
WHICH, IF ANY SAFETY DEVICES ARE
INSTALLED. OR NEEDED SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION. HOWEVER THE
LANGUAGE OF SB FOUR FOR TWO HAS
OFTEN BEEN MISINTERPRETED TO
SUGGEST THAT HOME INSPECTORS
MUST CONDUCT COMPREHENSIVE
SAFETY TESTS THAT ARE FAR BEHIND
THEIR CAPACITY OR THE INTENDED
SCOPE. FURTHER AS DRAFTED THE
LANGUAGE OF THE S S P FOUR FOR
TWO INADVERTENTLY ALLOWED FOR
SAFETY DEVICES TO BE INSTALLED
OR COMBINED IN WAYS THAT DO NOT
CREATE THE REDUNDANCY. THE
MEASURES SOUGHT TO ENSURE SB 552
ADDRESSES BOTH OF THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES FIRST BY
CLARIFYING THE ROLE OF HOME
INSPECTORS AND SECOND BY CLOSING
THE TWO STEP SAFETY DEVICE
LOOPHOLE, THEREBY ENSURING THAT
THESE LIVES LIFE SAVING FEATURES
ARE PROPERLY EMPLOYED TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY PREVENT CHILDHOOD
DEATHS AND INJURIES WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY, OR DAVE PACE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION AND STEVE
BARROW ON BEHALF OF THE ORIGINAL
SPONSORS OF SB 442. THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH. I
AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
I VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW PROCEED WITH OUR
WITNESSES. ARE WE USING THE
TABLE OR THE YOU EITHER WAY IS
FINE. YOUR IT'S TOTALLY FINE.
YEAH I PAID GOOD MONEY FOR THIS
TABLE. THEY USE THE TABLE. YEAH
AND IT WILL BE TWO MINUTES PER
LEAD WITNESS. ARE WE NOT? CAN WE
NOT WANT ME TO OKAY? YOU MAY
PROCEED. MY NAME IS, UH, THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. MY NAME IS STEVE
BARREL AND THE STATE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN'S SAFETY
AND HEALTH. WE AND I WAS
PERSONALLY ON THE TEAM THAT
HELPED DRAFT AND WRITE THE POOL
SAFETY ACT BACK IN 1996 WERE
ALSO AH, OF, UH PLEASANTLY THE
SPONSORS OR CO SPONSORS OF SP 44
TO THAT. ADDED THE REQUIREMENT
OF HAVING TO SAFETY BARRIERS AND
WE'RE REALLY HAPPY THAT THE
SENATOR KEEPS FOLLOWING UP AND
HELPING TO CLARIFY SOME
MISINTERPRETATIONS WITHIN THAT
BILL AND UPDATING THE, UH THE
DEFINITIONS THAT ARE CONTAINED
IN THEIR POOL SAFETY ACT VERY
IMPORTANT. THESE MIGHT SEEM JUST
ONLY TECHNICAL, BUT THEY WILL
SAY. THE LIVES OF CHILDREN. UM
AH, THE MISINTERPRETATION OF THE
TWO BARRIERS, ALLOWING SOME
PEOPLE TO MAKE A DECISION TO PUT
THE SAME BARRIER ON THE SAME
PLANE. THAT'S A DOOR. DEFEATS
WHAT THE LEGISLATION WAS DOING
IN 2017 BY ADDING A SECOND LAYER
SO WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL.
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
IT. I'M HERE FOR MORE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS DAVID PACE
. I'M A RECENTLY RETIRED REAL
ESTATE INSPECTOR. AFTER 30
YEARS. I CURRENTLY SERVE AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA REAL
ESTATE INSPECTION ASSOCIATION,
KNOWN AS CREA, WE ARE PLEASED TO
CO SPONSOR THIS WITH STEVE AND
HIS GROUP. I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR NEWMAN FOR HIS HARD WORK
HIS DEDICATION. TO POOL SAFETY.
WE BELIEVE THAT 552 PROVIDES
NEEDED CLARIFICATION FOR THE
HOME INSPECTORS. WHO ARE CHARGED
WITH CONDUCTING POOL SAFETY
FEATURE INSPECTIONS. WE BELIEVE
THAT PROVIDING BETTER CLARITY
FOR HOME INSPECTORS AS THEY
CONDUCT THEIR INSPECTIONS WILL
IN TURN, HELP US TO COMMUNICATE
WITH BETTER CLARITY TO BUYERS OF
HOMES THAT HAVE POOLS. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL, UH, ME TO
SUPPORT PLEASE? STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION. CHAIR
REMEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA POLLS, PA
ASSOCIATION AND THE POOL HOT TUB
ALLIANCE. WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE
WORKED WITH THE SENATOR AND BOTH
THESE GENTLEMEN, UM, ON THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
GREAT ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT, SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY TODAY? OKAY
SEE, NOW WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE, UH, COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MOTION BY SENATOR ONE
HOB. RIGHT? OKAY. GREAT SENATOR
CORDERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
CHAIR, SO JUST TO BE SO I
UNDERSTAND THE, UM THE CURRENT
OPPOSITION CONTINUES TO BE THE
BUILDING OFFICIALS CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND THE
COMMITMENT THAT YOU'VE MADE WITH
THEM AS TO KIND OF WORK OUT THE
LANGUAGE SO THAT IT'S CLEAR
EXACTLY HOW, UM THE. THE IT GETS
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. I
THINK EITHER OF THE SHIPS TO
GENERATE THIS IS ABOUT THE
ARTICULATION OF STANDARDS AROUND
INDUSTRY STANDARDS. BUT, MR
YEAH. THE BUILDING CODE
OFFICIALS WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
I MEAN, THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
DO THE ORIGINAL. WHEN YOU BUILD
A POOL OR YOU REMODEL IT. THEY
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO THEM AND
HOW THEY WORK WHEN THEY INSPECT
INSPECT THE POOL. THE OTHER
THING THAT WAS SUGGESTED IS THAT
THEY SHOULD, UM WORK WITH THEIR
COMMISSION TO FIGURE OUT WHICH
OF THESE BARRIERS WORK. THE BEST
. UM THE PROBLEM WITH THAT? IS
THERE NOT A STM INTERNATIONAL,
WHICH HAS THESE BIG LABORATORIES
WHERE THEY TEST THE MATERIALS TO
MAKE SURE THEY ACTUALLY DOES
THIS ACTUALLY, DOOR ALARM WORKED
AS THE POOL COVER WORK. THERE IS
ASKED ME 855 THAT YOU ALL PASSED
A COUPLE YEARS AGO, WAS JUST
RECENTLY FUNDED TO DO A STUDY OF
PILOT STUDIES OF HOW DO YOU
COLLECT BETTER INFORMATION RIGHT
AT THE INCIDENT SITE, SO WE ALL
KNOW IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE
SHOULD BE DOING WITH THIS LAW TO
MAKE IT EVEN STRONGER? SO I
THINK WORKING WITH THEM WILL
CONTINUE. WE ALWAYS LOOK TO THEM
AND WORK WITH THEM, BUT THAT'S
WHAT THEY WERE DOING. THEY THEIR
BIGGEST THING WAS. THE MANUAL
RELATED BILL ORIGINALLY WAS UH,
DRAFTED SO THAT MANUAL COVERS
WHICH ARE COVERED UNDER THE F 13
46-91 8 CM STANDARD WAS REMOVED.
AND NOW THAT HAS THE SENATOR HAS
PUT THAT BACK IN WORKING WITH
THE STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE'S
OKAY, AS LONG AS YOU'RE WORKING
WITH THEM, AND CAN REALLY
DIFFERENTIATE WHO DOES WHO HAS
THE CAPACITY AND THE ABILITY TO
DO THAT? THE TESTING AND THERE'S
DUAL, UM. THERE'S A BACKUP, I
GUESS IS THE WHOLE POINT OF IT.
WHICH IS THERE'S A BACKUP
SYSTEM. I'M RIGHT. AND IF I
WOULD IF I COULD EITHER WHOLE
POINT OF SB 442 FROM 2016, WHICH
CREATE REDUNDANCY, THIS BILL IS
DELIBERATELY CLEANUP BILL AND IT
COVERS REALLY TOO MANY AREAS.
ONE IS TO MR BARROWS BOY THAT
THAT QUESTION OF PLAIN IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IF TWO OF
THOSE BARRIERS WERE ON AT THE
SAME ENTRY POINT NOT USEFUL. THE
OTHER, PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT
ISSUE HERE IS ABOUT LANGUAGE
THAT CLARIFIES WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR INSPECTIONS, THE SCOPE OF
THOSE INSPECTIONS SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE PEOPLE DOING IT
DIFFERENT WAYS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW,
AGAIN LAST YEAR WE DID A BILL TO
COLLECT BETTER DATA. THERE IS
NOTHING MORE TRAGIC THAN A
RESIDENTIAL POOL DROWNING
PRECISELY BECAUSE IT'S SO
PREVENTABLE. SO YOU KNOW, THE
WHOLE POINT OF THIS REGIME IS TO
THE EXTENT ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE
TO PREVENT THESE UNNECESSARY
TRAGEDIES FROM OCCURRING. GET
IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
IT. GREAT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES. OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR ONE HOB
. THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS TODAY.
BUT THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
, UH, AND WITH THAT WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL AND I'M RECOMMENDING AN
AYE VOTE. YOU MAY CLOSE. THAT
WAS MY CLOTHES, BUT THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING. THANK YOU, MY WIFE. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND REFER. THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER WIENER. I SEE
ARTO ARTO BLAKE SPEAR. CABALLERO
CABALLERO, CORTEZ E. JONES JONES
. I. PADILLA DEA ICE SKINNER,
UMBERG HOB. UH HUH. BYE. 060
OKAY. THE VOTE IS 6 TO 0. WE
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL. UM LET'S
OPEN IT UP FOR SENATOR HAMBURG.
SENATOR UMBERG I. THAT'S 70.
OKAY WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS WERE
WAITING FOR US. SO WE'LL KEEP
THAT ON CALL AND HOPEFULLY,
THEY'LL BE HERE SHORTLY.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE. SENATOR SKINNER. OH IT'S
ON THE NEWMAN BILL. SB 552. IT'S
SEVEN. NOTHING. SKINNER. AYE.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING ON, THAT'S
RIGHT. OKAY I APPRECIATE IT. I
APPRECIATE IT. IT'S WE'RE ALL A
LITTLE RUSTY AFTER THE RECESS,
UM, EAT. NOTHING WILL PUT IT
BACK ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE ARE REOPENING THE
ROLE ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
SINGLE BILL THAT WE VOTED ON.
AND UH, WE NOW HAVE OUR MEMBER
SENATOR BLAKE SPEARS RETURNED.
SO THE BILL IS SP 55 TO, UM
SENATOR NEWMAN. UH, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AND WE REFER THE COMMUNITY
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR. COULD YOU PLEASE TELL ME
THE RESULTS OF THE PREVIOUS
VOTE? THE CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO
0, OKAY? AYE. THANKS FOR YOUR
EYE. ALRIGHT NOW WITH THAT SP
552 IS OH, I'M SORRY. WHO'S
STILL OKAY AND WHAT'S HE
INDICATED? ALRIGHT SO HE OKAY,
SO LOOK, WE DON'T NEED HIS VOTE.
IT CAN GET UP. SO WHY DON'T YOU
TEXT HIM AND SEE IF WE'RE GOING
TO CLOSE DOWN THE COMMITTEE? AH
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE DOWN THE
COMMITTEE IN THREE MINUTES. AND
IF HE'S NOT HERE, THANKS,
CATHERINE. TRANSPORTATION GREAT.
IF YOU SEE HIM, TELL HIM TO GET
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO DO THREE
MINUTES. OTHERWISE WE'RE CLOSING
THE RULE. YEAH. AH! BARBIE
DIDN'T GET TOO MANY GOLDEN
GLOBES.
HEY, LOOK AT THAT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ E ALRIGHT. UM THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE IS A AH COME
BACK TO ORDER AND WE HAVE, UH,
OUR LAST REMAINING MEMBER
SENATOR CORTEGE HAS RETURNED.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE AH, WE'RE AN
OPEN THE ROLL ON SP 55 TO THE
VOTES SO FAR IS 9 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR. VOTING? YES. AND STAFF.
COULD YOU OPEN THE RULE? SENATOR
COURTESY. IT'S COMPLETELY UP TO
YOU COURTESY. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ E S P.
552 PASSES, IT'S OUT, AND THE
VOTE WAS 10 TO 0. AND WITH THAT
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE IS A.